[Musik]
mit der anklage gegen lukas stadler
erreicht die staatsanwaltschaft die
richtigen wenngleich natürlich
vorauszusagen ist das auch gegen manager
eine unschuldsvermutung gilt trotzdem
ist es wichtig dass die
staatsanwaltschaft vor geht gegen die
manager gegen die konzernspitze und die
konzernspitze nicht damit durchkommt die
verantwortung für den skandal für all
die kriminellen machenschaften mit den
dieselmotoren und den betrug andenken
millionenfachen betrug an den kunden auf
mittlerer länge abzuweisen oder auf
einfach ingenieure die angeblich das
alles verbockt haben jetzt rupert
stadler fühlte sich lange unangreifbar
weil er eine besondere position hatte im
konzern
er war nicht nur formal
vorstandsvorsitzender von audi und dem
vw-konzern im vorstand sondern er hat
angefangen einst als büroleiter von
ferdinand piëch der damals allmächtige
in den vw-konzern hat später auch noch
die privaten finanzen von mitgliedern
der eigentümerfamilie verwaltet und
hatte deswegen musste er hatte immer die
schützende hand der familie der
milliardäre aus dem salzburger land über
sich und hat sich sehr gesträubt bei der
ganzen aufarbeitung und das war sicher
kein ruhmesblatt für das was an
transparenz versprochen wurde von dem
konzern von rupert stadler ist das alles
ein sehr tiefer fall fast tragisch
sondern seinen ruf hat er schon verloren
mit einem prozess verliert er womöglich
auch noch sein vermögen und oder gar
seine freiheit